so have a look at this it's a really
really condensed question it's very
small just a few symbols but there's a
lot of things to unpack it so before we
embark on actually doing this question I
want to notice three things okay first I
want to notice this guy at the front
right what does that mean again
differentiate so I think the first thing
I think is that's a bit weird because
you're asking you're differentiating
something that's an integral right it's
like whoa just make up your mind which
one you want to do so that just sort of
strikes me as strange okay
then you've got this thing here right
we've been looking at boundaries like
this which are just numbers okay but
this is a perineum rule it's variable
okay so that's something we would not
really encounter that very much before
so I'm just going to sort of raise that
as a point of suspicion but then the
last thing the third thing I notice is
this guy and this part just makes me go
angry because that looks like work all
right if we didn't know very much about
like the binomial theorem topic which we
did earlier in the year sorry let me
start that again if we didn't know very
much about calculus and all the rules
that we've developed then we're sort of
stuck with this you just got to expand
this beast out which will take you a
long time
you've got binomial theorem knowledge
though so you can do it but then that's
just time consuming and then you can do
it every single term okay so instead
what I want you to consider is this guy
here and think about what you would have
to do if you were differentiating this
right if you were differentiating this
you don't have to expand what would you
do you use the chain rule okay so know
what happens when we use the chain rule
on this if I differentiate this note
that I'm differentiating with respect to
t because that's the variable it's a
function of T is the way that we would
say that properly so what am I going to
do would you like to do the inside of
the outside first it doesn't matter
which is why 5050 I well I think I heard
outside louder so the outside is
something ^ all right so therefore for
comes out the front and then the power
reduces by one so we've done the outside
now the inside
is just negative six okay
I would simplify that I'd get my
derivative okay but I'm not
differentiating I am integrating okay so
I'm going to undo everything I just it
I'm gonna have to do it all in Reverse
okay so let's try this out right I'm
gonna go derivative because I this D on
DX I can't do anything with it yet
because this is all in terms of T's
right the derivative of and then I'm
going to put in the primitive now okay
so what do I think this is I brought the
power down reduce the power multiplied
by the derivative the inside so I want
to undo everything I think that means
I'm going to increase the power so it's
going to become seven minus sixteen to
the five no I'm not going to multiply by
that like I did over here I'm going to
divide there's the new power and then
the last thing over here was I
multiplied by the inside derivative well
to undo that I should divide by the
inside derivative like so okay now one
of the lovely things that integration is
that you can always no way that you were
right because you're quite good at
differentiation yeah we're gonna raise
the question are you just stretching
yeah what 7 minus 60
tell me which of those these steps your
step corresponds to in Reverse because I
think I did 3 things 1 2 3 that
corresponds to 1 2 3
yep yep ah that's a good question
let me show you when I take this guy
here which i think is the primitive okay
the easiest way to see if this really is
the primitive is to differentiate it
what happens when I differentiate it 7
minus 6 to the 5 on 5 times negative 6
that's really bad 5 sorry ok
what's gonna happen you can see in your
brain can't you what happens to is 5
what's the first thing I do with it I
multiply it out the front which cancels
with this yeah then what's the next
thing I do with the 5 it drops down to
or 4 I've done the outside now I'm going
to do the inside which means I multiply
by negative 6 so it's gone okay in some
ways it's because that's the way
differentiation works it's a constant
it's a constant is kind of a kid right
so negative 6 is the derivative that's
it okay there are different things if
that was a more complicated function in
there but we'll come to that a bit later
on okay when I was a student I had a
teacher and he gave us a sheet of a
revision sheet for calculus and on one
side there were derivatives on the other
side there were integrals and we were
finished a sheet and we'd say so where
are the answers and he said you just
made the answers because it was all the
perimeters on one side and all that and
it's like the ultimate trol move for a
math teacher anyway I'm not gonna do
that to you we've got a premium it looks
good we checked it out right but now
because it's a definite integral I need
to of course put my boundaries in okay
now thankfully because we're so good
algebra we know they're putting an axiom
substituting x in it's exactly the same
as putting a 2 in it's just that I'm
going to substitute it for this
particular variable does that make sense
we'll do the upper boundary then we'll
do the lower boundary here's what
happens when I put the twos in 7 minus
12 ^ v gross / negative 30 yep
- watch out for this by the way see how
this thing I have been a bit messy I
haven't tidied up this primitive very
much I probably should have put that
minus sign up there but you guys see
what's going on many many students
neglect negative signs that are inside
the primitive because they're like I
just I've got a negative sign there's a
double negative here this negative and
that negative and it's very common for
students to forget one or the other okay
I'm going to put my X's in now which is
easy 7 minus 6x on five divided by
negative thing how's that look
upper boundary lower boundary except I
forgot something and no one picked me up
on it which is this D on DX has been
hanging out the front for this whole
time okay so now I'm ready actually to
do a derivative now this thing looks
gross but thankfully the thing I'm doing
with it is differentiating what happens
when I differentiate this disaster what
is this thing it's just the constant it
might be a big awful constant but it's
just a constant so guess what happens
when you differentiate it it's gone all
right so I can ignore that and then I
just come over to here yeah uh let's see
here I've got to get rid of that double
negative cuz my brain hurts just looking
at it so I'm going to write 7 minus 6 X
to the 5 on 30 is that okay and in fact
you should recognize that function don't
she look what's going to happen fires
going to come out the front and is going
to cancel with I really shouldn't do it
on this line it's going to cancel with
the six so five seven minus 6x what
happens to the five at the top four
divided by
this 30 was already there right that's
the outside derivative colored you chain
rule yeah now I've got to do that inside
derivative which is negative six
okay so it looks like the five and the
six cancel with the 30 but there's still
a negative sign over there so minus
seven oh yeah so does anyone have any
questions
does it look okay so I know there are
some strange things in there and there
were some things that made us look like
a lot of work okay but every rule you
know from differentiation has its
parallel for integration right so
therefore like we had the chain rule
we've got the reverse chain rule and it
works in much the same way okay